Please be aware that the following video
contains massive spoilers for across the
spider verse including the very ending
of the film so
yeah
you've been warned
you can stick around if you want maybe
having the whole movie spoiled for you
is a Canon event or something I don't
know
all right
let's do this
[Music]
thank you
well folks
I have seen across the spider verse if
you want my overall thoughts on it in
more of a review format there's the
video where I did that it's over on my
secondary channel the break room of
Geeks but uh I cannot stop myself from
dipping into the discourse about it as
trans allegory or possible flat out
depiction of trans characters I say
possible because it is somewhat debated
amongst people now no character in this
is explicitly 100 stated as being trans
most of the discourse surrounds Gwen
Stacy and I will go over that
but if I'm being completely honest the
is Gwen Stacy trans discussion
that's kind of the low-hanging fruit for
me
I actually want to talk about
the whole movie
through a trans lens and give it a trans
reading now before we get too far along
let me clarify something right off the
bat
well actually two things first while I
will be touching on Gwen and going over
some of the things that lend themselves
to reading her as explicitly trans I'm
not actually here to try and settle or
make any argument is she canonically
trans or not because for my purposes it
doesn't really matter now you can make
an argument about whether or not it
should be explicit representation how
good a thing that would be and honestly
it probably would be a good thing but
that's not the conversation I want to
have right now regardless of whether she
is intended to be canonically trans or
not at the minimum she does canonically
support trans people because there is
the protect trans kids Banner in her
room so that part is absolutely
undeniable whether or not she herself is
intended to be trans again we'll get
into some of the bits of that but for
the most part I will say that regardless
of whether she herself is meant to be or
not her journey and certain aspects of
what happened to her character
throughout the movie absolutely only
lean into a trans reading of her
character and I do not believe for a
second that any of that was accidental
so we will be getting into that but the
other thing is that I need to remind
folks that doing a trans reading of a
piece of media is not the same thing as
claiming characters in it were
definitely meant to be trans I've gone
over this before I did a video a couple
years ago doing trans readings of
actually five films
um some of which did very much have
indications that they were actually
meant to be read at least partially
through a trans lens and others where it
was just me giving that reading because
giving that kind of reading to A piece
of media means analyzing it through that
lens looking at it and thinking how do
the experiences and the events depicted
here map onto a trans experience what
things that a trans person is likely to
have experienced could be related to in
this film
and on a similar basis I did an entire
queer and at points explicitly trans
reading of Peter Capaldi's 12th doctor
There's the link for that one and no
that's not me saying that the 12th
doctor is canonically trans but it is me
saying that his journey his character
Arc spoke to me deeply as a trans person
and I explained why
so while I am going to be doing a trans
reading of across the spider-verse as a
complete piece
this is not me saying that anyone other
than Gwen is trans and again I'll touch
on Gwen and I'm not even really going to
say definitively that she definitely is
but we are still going to touch on that
nor am I saying that miles or any other
characters like they're definitely trans
I'm claiming them no I'm not but I'm
applying a trans lens to this because
it fits on a hell of a lot more than
just Gwen
but let's start there let's start with
Gwen so first of all there is a lot of
the visual coding there's the obvious
thing that I mentioned of the uh protect
trans kids Banner that she had in her
room but they've also added pink into
her hair now pink in and of itself is
just one color and most
um Pride banners of any kind have
minimum three colors involved in them
and that is also true of the trans flag
which for point of reference looks like
this now it is worth noting first of all
that while it is not a universal truth
that all Queer people get a non-natural
color put in their hair
um
it is a bit of a stereotype uh and it is
a bit of a stereotype for a reason it is
a thing that happens but that certainly
in and of itself is not a massive
indicator however there is also a lot of
lighting there's a lot of very
deliberate lighting and color choices
across her scenes it is not uncommon
especially when she is in conversation
with her father for her to be lit in a
way that brings pink and blue highlights
to the scene and let me remind you that
her outfit is predominantly white so
blue pink and white
those being the colors of the trans flag
and you have to realize
that was a deliberate Choice every time
that happens this is an animated film
there is no accidental Quirk of lighting
there's no uh visual effect that could
have happened by accident every single
thing is a choice that was made because
it all had to be created from scratch so
this lighting is not an accident and
that's kind of what I meant when I said
that I do believe that it is pretty much
impossible to argue that Gwen has not
designed with the ability to read her as
trans being built in even if that is not
intended to be the canonical read on the
character because specifically Oh and
before I get into this uh let me be
clear from here on out spoilers for the
movie because I am going to be talking
about the whole thing but that's your
warning don't watch this if you haven't
seen the movie yet or maybe you just
don't care about spoilers in that case
stick around but when she has her big
confrontation towards the end with her
father during the heart of her speech of
what is in many ways a coming out speech
or at the very least a confrontation
following a bad coming out she is pacing
back and forth in that kitchen and she
is lit pink blue super deliberately it's
waving through her hair it's in the
background it is really really
deliberate and it's especially for a
scene like that it's really hard to not
read it as a connection
to a trans person trying to find some
common ground or trying to confront or
even call out someone who matters to
them in their life who initially
rejected them
I mean that is what she's doing
regardless of whether you want to map it
on to a trans experience canonically
that is what she's doing she's
confronting her dad who when he first
realized and found out that she was
Spider Woman he rejected her
and now they're having a confrontation
about it and almost everything she says
could be repurposed almost one to one as
a conversation between a trans person
and they're initially unaccepting parent
it's really upfront it's pretty pretty
blatant and it's incredibly easy
to read the trans allegory in that and
that includes the earlier parts of what
happened between her and her father
because
as I said initially he does reject her
and it's not just that she is something
that he's uncomfortable with
is that she lied to him
and that can be the part that stings for
some people
for some people who are like I thought
you trusted me and you've been lying to
me for how long
about this and even if that isn't
something that happens that's something
that a lot of queer people fear
that even if the person that they know
they should come out to has not
expressly made disparaging remarks for
what they are
that they're still going to be mad that
it was kept from them
or in the case of Gwen Stacy's dad both
are relevant because he's a captain who
has been actively hunting Spider-Woman
so he's made clear his thoughts on her
and also
there's
the pain
of being lied to
and that's part of why the later scene
where Gwen is lit up in very trans
colors is so powerful
and it was one of like I basically
choked up and teared up uh if not flat
out cried at pretty much every single
scene between Gwen and her dad but this
one especially when she does the big
confrontation with him
because
he really does come across as analogous
to a parent
who in the moment
from the shock from the confusion from
the overwhelming just trying to process
everything that he's just learned
reacted badly
and is trying to do better isn't
doubling down
but doesn't really know what to do to
make it right either
it's really beautiful
so that's Gwen and as I said incredibly
easy to do a trans reading on here and
indeed more than a few are arguing that
she is canonically intended to be trans
and then there's a whole side argument
over whether if that was the intention
for her should they have just flat out
said it instead of super coding it
because this isn't even coding this is
super coding and that's a conversation
that I think is worth having
it's just not the one I'm gonna have
today
but I said I wanted to expand the trans
reading further out and apply it to more
than just Gwen
because I do
I want to apply it
to Miles and indeed
the entire movie
because first of all
there is an inherent
transness to the core conceit of
Spider-Man and it ties into what I've
just said with Gwen which is that when
you have this relationship this Dynamic
with people who matter to you who love
you and you love them
but there's something that you've been
keeping from them something that's very
fundamental about who you are
that you haven't told them either
because they have expressly stated a
dislike for that thing that you are or
just out of fear of rejection or fear of
anger that you've been keeping it or all
of the above
that is a very trans experience and that
applies to pretty much
every version of Spider-Man
they pretty much all have that so we
already start with the fact that a core
conceit of how Spider-Man always works
is a very trans analogous experience
and it is interesting with Spider-Man in
particular because he's one of the few
who's
secret identity
really matters
because his ability or often inability
to juggle his private life in a
superheroing life is really at the core
of the character in a way that it rarely
is anymore and even most of the older
characters who had secret identities
initially it didn't matter to the degree
that it does with Spider-Man
so you have this core Central conceit
that maps onto trans experiences quite
well
and that applies again to all of them
pretty much so the entire film
but there's some more stuff with miles
in particular because there's part of
the experience that Miles has
that I think maps onto a much more
specific
trans experience
and it's one that I wish
that I have not
experienced or hadn't seen or wasn't
still seeing in certain aspects in
certain places
but I have
and as a trans experience not often
talked about
even from within the community
so
here's the thing about miles
compared to all the other spider people
it's an anomaly
which first of all was just brilliant
and I'm shocked I didn't see that
specific aspect coming that because the
spider that bit him wasn't from his
Universe he was never supposed to be
Spider-Man
the Peter Parker from his Universe was
not supposed to die and the spider that
bit him was supposed to bite somebody
else in a completely different universe
he's already disruptive
by his very existence
and oftentimes
not meaning to be
trans people
particularly those that don't fit the
clean narrative
and the binary of trans man and trans
woman clean transition of one gender
identity to what is considered to be the
opposite one
but instead falling on the non-binary
Spectrum somewhere
or even
being on the binary Spectrum but not
conforming to the common story
it is
not an uncommon experience
to be made to feel like an anomaly
by virtue of Who You Are
even within your community
because that's the thing this was
another aspects of Gwen's story when she
had the rejection from her father she
fled
but she found Community she found people
like her it's even said explicitly that
huby let her crash with him
she was caught by a community of people
like her when she was rejected by her
family and I will continue to point out
things like the fact that trans people
in particular even amongst the queer
population are more likely to be ejected
from their homes
it is often that community
that will hopefully catch you
if you have it and if you can find it
and it Gwen does find it
and miles
thinks
he found it
but he gets
rejected
because even within that community
he is seen as anomalous
as a hazard
as a danger to the rest of them
how does that map onto a trans
experience
unpleasantly
speaking as someone who 10 years ago and
more tried to Grapple with the idea that
I was a cisgender man who cross-dressed
and
was not actually
some form of trans myself
I found
a bit of rejection
from the queer community
and I suppose given the way I was
identifying although I never identified
as straight but
I was straight passing
and I thought I was cisgender
and I want to be very clear the
community as a whole didn't reject me
but certain people did
certain trans people did
they felt that me just being
and at the time I thought I was this too
a guy who puts on dresses
they felt that my existence somehow
endangered or diminished their own
and that's something that would be
reinforced and would come up again even
after
I came to terms with myself as gender
fluid
because if you're not familiar with the
term transmedicalist
these are people within the trans
Community who are very committed to the
binary and
push forward the idea that the only
valid way to be trans is to go through
full medical transition and that if you
either haven't done or don't intend to
do that
you're not really trans
or you're not valid as a trans person
and if you're somewhere on the
non-binary Spectrum or if you're gender
fluid like I am you are super not valid
as a trans person and if you have very
little or indeed no dysphoria driving
you to embrace Who You Are
transmedical is really reject that
um just as point of reference if the
idea of being trans without having
dysphoria is confusing to you because
it's confusing to a lot of folks I have
actually done a video on that on one of
my other channels so if you want to
pause this and go take a look at that so
you understand what I mean when I say
that so I don't have to cover it all
again here you can do that but again
it's that sense of
rejection
coming from within the community
and recently
we have seen in a number of forms
members of the lgbtqia plus community
trying to reject or remove trans people
from that equation
you have lesbians who identify as part
of the gender critical or turf movement
especially in the UK where they have put
a lot of effort into removing the T from
LGBT you can have
people like certain
CIS gay men who will make an argument
that the gay community should not
support trans people
despite trans people having been part of
gay and queer rights
from the literal beginning of pride
and regardless of the reasons for this
be it some sort of inherent or
um cultivated bigotry against trans
people or be it as a survival thing out
of fear because they see
other things happening to trans people
all the attacks coming from certain
aspects of society and social media and
even the legislature and a lot of areas
especially in the United States in
places like Florida or Texas and many
other states
and there may be fear
from queer people who aren't trans
seeing that and worrying that the attack
on trans people will bleed over onto
them by association
that they will all be dragged down
but regardless of the reason
whether it is a bigotry whether it is a
fear like I just described it doesn't
matter
you still feel that rejection
and now to be very very clear
this is not a case of the entire
community that you thought would embrace
you turning on you that's not the
literal reality the aspects of the
lgbtqia plus community that do this are
Fringe elements they get unfortunately
disproportionate voices because they get
boosted by people who don't like us who
aren't even part of the lgbtqia plus
Community but they are a minority they
are a tiny minority whereas in across
the spider verse in the movie
all the spider people
go against miles including the ones that
he vote closest to at least initially
the thing is while in the movie they
pretty much all turn on him or at least
initially seem to I'll come back to that
and whereas in reality it's going to be
a small sliver of people turning against
you
it feels
bigger
what happens then across the spider
verse the idea of every single person
that you relate to and identify with and
you thought you had Community with
turning on you
is how it feels
when these things happen
so across the spider versus true to the
emotion
of that happening
if not a clean mapping on to the reality
of it
but then there's the other Factor
which is I mentioned
you know
the whole Community seems to turn on him
but also not really Gwen has a lot of
doubts Peter B Parker has a lot of
doubts and then by the end
we see her him and also a bunch of
characters from the first movie
commit
to being with him and trying to fight
alongside him
for what is good for him even if it's in
opposition to the rest of the community
because ultimately
while in the moment
maybe the whole Community turned on him
that was ultimately driven
by one person
and that was Miguel
because the community trusts in him
and he has given his reasons his
rationale
but at the same time he's very
emotionally biased
his attempts to
live the kind of life and do the kind of
thing that Miles has expressed he wants
to do ended horribly for him
so he has a very emotionally driven bias
against what miles is and what miles
will do
another interesting thing to note about
Miguel but also his primary allies at
least initially those being Peter B
Parker and Jessica Drew is that they are
older
Than Miles than Gwen presumably than
huby and their experiences of being
Spider-Man of being this community
is defined by pain quite literally both
Miguel and Peter B Parker make an
argument that the sacrifice and the
losses that they suffered are defining
to who they are to the very nature of
themselves what about Uncle Ben if not
for Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be
here which is what transmedicalists say
about dysphoria they Define being trans
as being pain and they see trans people
who say I don't experience that level of
pain or I don't think that should be
what defines us as invalid and Miguel is
trying to stop miles who is attempting
to be Spider-Man
absent some of that pain and while age
is not the sole defining factor in this
kind of divide it is worth noting that
much the community that holds on to
these beliefs tend to be
a bit on the older side and it is
younger queer people who are
increasingly pushing against that
narrative and saying we are part of this
community but we do not need to be
defined by that
and so I said
it wasn't true to the reality because in
reality the entire
um Community doesn't turn on you
but it feels like it but in reality the
entire Community didn't really turn on
Miles like they defaulted to what
someone they trusted said because
they didn't know what else to do but as
they come to better understand the
situation
more and more of them
aren't ready to do what Miguel says
now thankfully by and large the aspects
within the queer community that are
trying to push out trans people are not
the leaders that everyone follows
universally on Instinct we actually
don't really have a ton of those within
the queer community in the first place
within smaller or more localized areas
maybe but not collectively as a whole
because you know what uh this messy
quirky group that I have Community with
oh we ain't a monolith
not by a long shot
so there is that difference between
reality and the film in terms of a trans
reading that Miguel is able to direct
the entire Community to action whereas
that's not really how it happens but
if certain people who are within the
community who do
turn against trans people or a certain
kind of trans people because as I said
even within the trans Community you can
get
transmaticalists or you can get people
who just
seem to not want anyone else to have a
positive trans experience even if they
themselves did
it gets very weird sometimes
and that can come from directly within
the trans community
some of these people
have followings
how many of the people who follow them
are also part of the queer Community is
often uh debatable
but they still have followings
it can still feel if you've ever been
targeted by anyone like this
it can still feel
like an army is descending on you
but oh
the feeling of realizing that there are
people still on your side which
unfortunately miles doesn't have yet
that's being saved for the next one but
that
also brings me to the cliffhanger
because yeah I'm not done
I owe one more bit of transness to read
into this
the cliffhanger
the reveal
of miles from a universe
where the spider originally came from
the miles
who should have been bitten
and wasn't
and whose life has gone
in a very different direction
a terrifying one
a life of not only crime but of violence
and in many ways
miles confronting this alternate version
of himself this version of himself that
became the prowler
it feels more than a little
by getting a glimpse
of who you would have become
if you didn't become the person you were
meant to be
and finding that horrifying
because I think
if I ever got a glimpse
of a version of myself
who is the age I am now
who didn't come to terms
with who they are who didn't become who
I know I am
I think that would horrify me
and I think miles's reaction
fits
for that kind of reading
of seeing
who you would have been
if you weren't this key core fundamental
thing that you know you are
but if you weren't that
would you like that person
if you're trans and you've ever asked
yourself anything like that the answer
is I know
no almost definitely not
I'll be really curious to see
where this goes
in the next movie
because the next film may or may not
lend itself to as much of a trans
reading as this one did
but my friends
if you so desire to read it as such
across the spider versus
really trans
not just Gwen the whole movie
what are your thoughts on anything that
I've laid out agree disagree again keep
in mind this was a reading of the text
this is me applying a certain critical
lens this is not me saying that miles is
intended to be a trans character so like
don't give me that you all you'll do is
expose the fact that you either didn't
watch the video or did not actually
listen to me and didn't pay attention
but uh whatever your thoughts may be
agree or disagree drop them down in the
comments and let's talk about it
patreon is how I am able to do this as
my living any supporters of great help
but even if you can't do that like share
subscribe also help there's links to
other things that I do down in the
description
but
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for nobody likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
foreign
you know what's kind of funny with my
hair because like initially when I
colored it this this was a much more
vibrant magenta and like you can see
underneath a little bit more what that
was originally but it was more of a teal
but now that it's starting to fade this
is more of a pink and that's more of a
light blue and uh so it's almost like
I've got the trans flag in my hair and
if you find yourself going oh what but
isn't there white in there like I'm 41
look closer there's there's plenty of
white mixed in there too
yeah yeah I did a post-credits scene
what